[Music]
big night I mean we know if you think
back there's one for making this and you
look at you now and all the attention
did you did you think it was gonna catch
on a viewing become what what if it's
bad if I say no it was like maybe it'll
find a niche you know it's Michonne
riffing lieutenant it really became sort
of an overwhelming thing and it was it
was it was great we were thrilled and it
is again you guys have started shooting
season two correct yeah yeah we are bran
we're finishing how would you describe
it in like just a few words I think all
I'm allowed to say is that it's one year
later all right
a little contraband so but ammo tandra
1984 very key very Laura well Ian all
right you know like the aftermath and
new news there's new cast members that
have joined up yes I love interest
perhaps yes can I sit yeah it's been
that edge yes John Astin john erskine
how long did ii Joe Rudi not very long
actually I decided to Fargo stylist and
just go as myself and why my illness
causes oh well this is my friend Ryan
Roche beautiful dress and I own maple I
stole a stuff and my grandmother's
you